foreign
your career in a new country that too in
a new sector after a career break is
anything but easy I faced my share of
challenges and I'm glad that I took the
right decision at the right time to
upskill myself this course helped me to
restart my career in digital marketing
after a gap of three years hi my name is
riti and I am a digital marketer by
profession I am a mother of two
beautiful children and we live in
Atlanta Georgia I got married and I
moved to States in 2014 back in India I
was working as a PR consultant when I
moved here I got my work permit and I
landed my first job here that was in
Comcast it was a sales profile I worked
there for some time and in 2018 when I
was expecting my second child I decided
it to take a break from work
I was blessed with a daughter so in 2021
when my daughter turned three and my son
was a little older so I thought now this
is the time I can focus on my career
things did not work out for me as I
thought it would I did my research and I
realized that digital marketing is a
growing field I already had experience
in sales and public relations so I
wanted to learn digital marketing so I
opted a professional certification
program in digital marketing from Purdue
University offered by simply learn this
course gave me an understanding about
SEO social media marketing web analytics
and email marketing
these courses are very well designed for
beginners the best part about this
course are the live classes that keeps
you on your schedule our Mentor was very
well informed about each topic on the
basis of my past experience and on my
newly developed skill I landed my first
freelance project with a company called
country Edge this happened when I
completed my certification I am working
with them the best part about this job
is it is remote I can stay at home I can
be with my kids and I can also focus on
my hobbies too multitasking can be
overwhelming sometimes but if you have
the right skill you can get rid of all
the obstacles that come your way